good morning Sona good morning Elia so
what I wanted to do is briefly give an
overview of the program and a little
introduction as the program that we work
together seamlessly and so briefly
introduced again the program is called
genomics in the virtual lab I will have
a number of speakers throughout the
program but because this is their first
time meeting I wanted to make sure that
everybody understands how with different
elements I'm going to work together so
first of all about myself I work with a
company called Pine biotech and we
actually develop a lot of educational
resources and technology and solutions
for both research and education and we
have the privilege of working with a
number of collaborators and different
university labs that that are
specialized in a lot of different types
of omics data and our goal as a company
is to really make bioinformatics more
accessible to a wider number of users
that includes biologists clinicians
students people that are just getting
interested in bioinformatics that are
maybe thinking about what degrees they
will pursue in their future careers and
so we try to make sure that the
bioinformatics methods and logic is
clear and understandable and it can be
effective in the hands of those that are
interested and pursuing a research
question so we have developed a number
of these resources and some of them
we'll be using throughout this program
in this course will also continue to
develop these kinds of materials they
include tutorials they include some
software solutions but also they include
these kinds of programs so this is just
one of the programs that we run we have
a number of other ones and some of you
might have been a part of these previous
programs or might have been Expo
materials about these programs so by
participating in this program today
you'll have a chance to kind of see what
these programs are and what do they give
you at the end of the program course so
this program is going to be looking at a
variety of different types of omics data
we'll talk a lot about the relationship
between the sequence and the structure
and we'll talk about the relationship
between biology and data we'll look at
how these complex biological processes
could be studied by looking at data and
of course when it comes to data there
are a number of different types of omics
data we'll cover that a lot more in
detail but a lot of these sequencing
techniques and and techniques to
generate the data allow us to study at a
very detailed level what goes on inside
cell the cell and surprisingly by
looking at what goes on inside the cell
we can actually solve challenges and
problems that are typical in biomedical
research including a number of different
clinical as well as pharmaceutical and
biotechnology challenges so those of you
that are interested in biomedical
research and are thinking about clinical
applications of bioinformatics as well
as applications of bioinformatics and
pharmaceutical companies and
biotechnology companies we believe that
the materials that you'll be exposed to
in this program will help you understand
how data is becoming a major focus for a
lot of these applications and hopefully
you'll get a chance to apply some of
these tools with your own hands
and develop some research questions
about important diseases and conditions
and also see how to actually answer
those questions with some of these tools
so I also want to introduce you to dr.
Soto Vasudha she is a program director
and professor
to biochemistry at Georgetown University
Medical Center and and she has a lot of
experience both in teaching and in
research I want to give over the
microphone to her to briefly maybe
introduce yourself in a few words and
then I'll do a little program overview
after this yeah that's Thank You Ilya
hello everyone I'm extremely excited and
I hope you all enjoy the two weeks we
will try to do our best to keep you
engaged my background is actually
physics I'm a physicist by training and
then I switched to applications so you
know physics into the field of
bioinformatics and biology and I run a
master's program which is master's
program in systems medicine so teaching
is my passion and you know I've been
doing this for over ten years and I am
really looking forward to the week with
you all and let's have a fruitful
effective interactive session this week
and it's it's a pleasure for us to have
you here and we all hope to learn from
you because you do have a lot of
experience so let's go over some of the
program materials and talk about what we
will cover in two weeks that will meet
every day for a couple of hours so this
program is called genomics in the
virtual lab and we have organized the
materials so that we first covered a
number of bioinformatics tools and
datasets that we will cover and then
we'll transition to focus on genomics
and biomedical research so in the first
week we'll talk about introduction to
bioinformatics discuss protein structure
and function look at multiple sequence
alignment and phylogeny and look at
mutations and 3d structures of proteins
how those mutations could be mapped onto
these 3d structures
and we'll also have a guest lecture and
have some weekend activities for you
then in week 2 we'll talk about how to
do research literature review and design
your project we'll talk about genomics
and application to biology and
infectious diseases look at microbial
communities and AI bodies and how we can
study the microbiome and also discuss
antiviral drugs vaccines and antibiotics
and we hope that as a result of these
two weeks each one of you will be able
to come out with some kind of a mini
project presentation we'll talk about
such diseases as sickle cell anemia
cystic fibrosis and others and so we
hope that as a result of using a number
of the tools that we've prepared little
tutorials and examples with you'll be
able to appreciate the relationship
between sequence and function and will
be able to answer any questions that you
might have as you start without in your
research projects now I do want to
mention that we have a chat and in this
chat you'll be able to ask questions so
what we'll do is we'll review the
program coursework which is which are
the sessions that I've described now
then we'll talk about some facilitating
kind of infrastructural things that will
help us track everybody's progress and
help you make the most out of your time
but during this whole time please feel
free to ask any questions in the chat
however we have a number of people that
are going to be supporting this program
so Sona will be doing most of the
teaching in the first part of the
program we'll have a number of guest
speakers and other trainers but as in
any session you can actually ask
questions in the chat and we'll address
those we have specific time points where
we'll stop and can answer those
questions okay so in week one will talk
about bioinformatics tools and the
datasets so big part of bioinformatics
is organizing
data sets in making them accessible and
different different tools are designed
for different types of analysis so we'll
talk about our platform that will allow
you to do big data processing and we'll
talk about different visualization tools
and tools that will allow you to compare
different sequences and we'll also
introduce you to a number of resources
where you can spend time independently
of the sessions that we have and learn
more about some of these tools and
methods of analysis so we'll talk about
introduction to bioinformatics and the
different omics technologies the problem
of big data and bound medicine and
research and we hope that as a result of
this first session you'll get an
overview of data businesses and
resources that are available to carry
out data-driven research in life
sciences we'll talk then about protein
structure and function because the
sequences that we analyze end up being
functional proteins and it's important
to understand the relationship between
the DNA sequence and the protein
structure and then we'll talk about how
to analyze the sequences in both
nucleotide and amino acid form and to
understand what are the important
differences for us to focus on and how
phylogenetic relationship could be
inferred from multiple sequence
alignment then we'll talk about how
mutations or individual changes in the
sequences could be mapped onto the 3d
structures of proteins and so we'll
learn about tools like PI mole and
chimera to discuss how we can visualize
and find specific points in the proteins
and then it we'll talk about how we can
actually find interesting datasets and
take those data from different publicly
available repositories now in view of
our weekend that's gonna come after this
session
we'll do a little review and we'll have
a guest lecture to talk about the
protein databank and we'll also have
some interactive activities and weekend
activities for you for that weekend
so we'll discuss those in detail at a
later time but in the second part of the
program will actually start talking
about genomics in research in
application to basic and translational
research and we'll talk about how you
can make the most out of this program to
prepare a project of your own so we'll
actually talk about literature review
and designing your project we'll give
you some examples of projects that have
been developed by us as examples
specifically for teaching but also some
student example projects that you can
see and evaluate for what you might be
interested in we'll talk about genomics
and hydrology one of the major aspects
of kind of outcomes of this genomic
revolution has been our ability to
understand the world of viruses and
microbes and really see them in you know
detect them and categorize them and
characterize them we'll talk about the
microbiome and different types of
microbiome studies that are allowed by
what's called 16s ribosomal RNA amplicon
sequencing will talk about vaccines
antibiotics and antiviral drugs and
we'll use the NCBI virus project which
is a new project by the National Center
for Biotechnology information that was
recently released where you can find a
lot of information on different types of
viral genomes and other datasets about
viruses for the weekend we'll hope that
by that time each one will have a
project presentation prepared throughout
those two weeks and we will talk about
how to improve those and make them ready
for presentation and then we'll have a
panel of judges that are experts in
different bias max fields that will give
you personal feedback on the projects
that you develop and
at this time we hope that you will be
able to apply some of the tools that
we've discussed to some of the data sets
that we will introduce you to do
literature review do your own analysis
or maybe work in groups together with
someone else
develop a research project and the
presentation and recorded so that it
could be reviewed by this panel of
judges are there any questions about any
of these sessions that we are planning
for and yet if you have any questions
you're welcome to put those in chat or
as we go along you can also think of
other questions that you might have I
will show you now where you can find a
detailed syllabus and how to complete
your registration if you have not
completed it yet so I know that some of
you here are already registered some of
you might have been interested in but
have not had time to complete the
registration so let me introduce you to
some of those important links where you
will find all of this information so the
way the program registration happens is
and yes there is a certificate for this
course as well so and I'll show you in a
little bit how to get the most out of
this program so there is a link for
pre-registration where you will find a
form to fill up and in this form we will
be asking you questions about your
background and about your interests and
the objective of that is to really make
sure that the program is a good fit for
you after you fill out this information
you will get an email about all of the
program details including the
registration link and in that
registration link you can actually
complete your registration now in this
registration link you will be introduced
to our science coach training portal so
the science coach training portal will
provide you with a lot of resources that
we'll be referring to throughout this
program and you'll be able to see your
progress as you go through some of the
materials that we have
so let's briefly take a look at this
site okay so here's the site you will
have to register on this site the
registration itself is actually free but
you end up with a profile and so once
you are registered and logged in you
will see your name pop up right here and
then you can go to programs and this is
the program that we are in is genomics
in the virtual lab so if you go to
programs and find genomics in the
virtual lab so once you get there it
looks like this you will start seeing
here updates from people that have to
join the program and you'll see a number
of additional program resources right
here in the secondary menu for example
we will have a forum where you can post
any questions and we will have
discussions about some of the technical
methods or linked to different datasets
that we do or maybe a detailed
explanation on how to install a
particular piece of software that we're
going to be using you will also see a
number of courses these are going to be
a synchronous self-paced courses that
you can complete and for each one of
those courses you will get a certificate
of completion with your name on it some
of those will include practical
assignments then we will have a number
of project examples for you to review
there will be progress tab where you can
actually look at where the whole group
is in terms of their progress of
completing the different materials that
we have and you will also see a syllabus
right here for some of you you know if
your screen is not wide enough you will
have to click on menu and click on the
syllabus so this syllabus includes a
detailed overview of these sessions that
we have discussed and what will be
covered in each session for some of
these sessions you will also see an
additional resource which is which could
be a course or a project a project would
be a data set that we'll be reviewing
with an Associated publication
so that's a little bit about the program
again to join the program you have to
create a profile a user profile and this
user profile is a centralized place for
you to track all of your activity so let
me briefly tell you about some of the
coursework that you will be able to
access during the course of this program
we have a variety of courses starting
from introduction to bioinformatics to
an overview of genomics transcriptomics
at the genomics metagenomics and an
introduction to machine learning for
biomedical data all of these are around
your own individual profile in that
profile you will see points accumulating
as you go through some of the course
material and you will see your progress
and completion of courses for which you
will get a certificate of completion in
these courses you will find a number of
resources that are timed so again you
can go through and see how much time
will be required to complete each lesson
there are terms that are explained if
you're not familiar with the terminology
of bioinformatics or even in molecular
biology we try to make sure that those
are explained well you will see here on
top a number of additional tools for you
to use for example you can download a
course outline you can download the PDF
materials you can also see a lesson
forum where you can ask questions and
get clarification or any issues or
questions that you might have and so
this is a resource and additional
resource that you will get access to
apart from just the sessions on zoom'
like today okay so some questions here
I'm a beginner how would I derive
maximum benefit from this program I
don't mind fast-track reading so we'll
talk about the you know objective of the
program is to really give you an
introduction and also give you some
hands-on
practice so if you are participating in
the sessions and if you go through the
additional materials that we ask you to
look at throughout the program you will
need at least three to four hours a day
to really get the most out of this
program because we will need for two
hours every day in sessions like these
potentially if you have any questions or
if you have any challenges with
downloading software or maybe preparing
for an assignment you know that will
require a little bit more time so that
it doesn't have to be four hours at you
know in one chunk you can join the
session and then take a break and then
come back and do some more time
okay other questions here okay Thank You
Sona and beeps are answering some of
those okay so let me complete some of
these additional logistical slides again
your profile is also something that is
an outcome for you as you complete some
of these resources and materials so we
will look at how you complete some of
these courses we have a number of
exercises that are graded some of the
exercises are going to be for you to
practice some of them are going to be to
earn points and as those points
accumulate we will actually introduce
you to our leader board on this leader
board we highlight and feature the most
active students that have the most
points throughout the program that we
will do will also give you access to our
cloud-based email info platform on this
platform you will have a number of tools
that you'll get access to that do not
require you to be familiar with
bioinformatics or know how to code so
the important benefit of this platform
is that you will be able to process
large datasets and apply complex methods
without the need of coding in the
platform you will build pipelines these
bioinformatics pipelines allow you to
understand the logic of analysis they
are color coded so you understand why
each button
what kind of function it performs
they're explained methods that you can
click a link and read more about it
deals with a variety of input and output
formats and also provide some guidance
so that you don't have to make any major
mistakes as you go through some of those
steps some of those will be available as
practical assignments that you can do in
R and Python so again this is going to
be more for the second part of the
program when we deal with some of those
examples that were described in week 2
but you will be able to practice some of
the materials in our own Python if that
is something that you would like to do
so there we will provide you with some
code you will be able to run that code
and modify it to really understand what
kinds of datasets you can analyze with
these methods and what do they perform
what kind of function do they perform
again all of these are graded and you
will get points for completing specific
assignments for this first week we will
focus on Pinal so we do ask you that you
already start preparing for the program
download download the Pineville software
on your computer and dr. Basu d'avin
will be going through how to start
applying it to different types of data
in the second part of the program we
will also touch on chimera which is
another similar software tool that is
commonly used and a lot of research
studies for visualization and some
analysis okay I do want to mention that
there is a number of additional people
that have contributed to making these
programs possible dr. Alfred caliber and
dr. Lena Brodsky and are the founders of
Hein biotech and they also are the major
leaders at the caliber mathematics
research center which is a Research
Center at the University of Haifa in
addition to their guidance we have a
number of team members that have been
preparing the platform and the
coursework and will be supporting your
activity
throughout this program answering your
questions sending out emails making sure
that you know where to find what so I do
want to focus on beep sir
who is our community manager and you'll
be getting a lot of emails from her so
please do keep those emails in a
separate inbox if you have any questions
about zoom links or where to find a
specific course that we are covering etc
you'll be able to reach out to her and
she will help you find them yes and
beeps I also put in the chat there so
you can add her email marketing at Pine
dot bio to your contact so you don't
lose any of those events okay so any
questions written related to primal and
what we will be doing I will let dr.
stone of a suit event and answer those
so unless you have any other questions I
will transfer it over to her so that she
can guide us through what she has
planned for this session Thank You Leah
so let me share my screen okay so Thank
You Leah so Ilya took away some of the
part that I wanted to talk about in
terms of explaining what the first week
will look like so since he has already
done that I'm just going to go and
switch gears to get started already so
the way I like to work is I would love
to have an interactive session and so as
and when you have a question I know beep
sure is actually monitoring the chart
and I can look and once in a while as
well or I'm not sure if you're allowed
to a mute and ask the question so the
goal is today it's just to have an
introduction so it's completely an
introductory lecture so for those who
are very very new to the whole field of
bioinformatics so there is no
complicated tools or resources we are
going to be doing today this is just an
introduction and let's see how
interactive we can get
so I'm gonna begin okay so this is
something that I wanted to talk to you
about but since Ilya has already told
you what we gonna do I'm just going to
skip this slide but today what I'm gonna
do is you will learn by the end of the
day you should learn what bioinformatics
actually means if you google a bio
markets they're gonna get millions and
millions of records in Google which
means it's an important term to know and
this is a definition that I have come up
with and this is a definition I hope
will make sense to everyone and we're
all talking about big data big data big
data so what I'm going to talk to you
about what are the challenges we're
facing today because of the big data and
also where is all this big data actually
coming from that Ilya was talking to you
about all different research projects
that we can do and how can we look at
diseases so I'm going to introduce you
to all the where the data is actually
coming from and what it means and how we
can actually use so today we're just
going to get introduced to the big data
where all these data is coming from and
because of all of this big data we have
given birth to your whole new field of
genomics right so that is what we're
going to be focusing on today so now
before we define what bioinformatics is
I want to talk to you about what is
informatics so if you want to take a
stab at what informatics is you can
start typing in the chat and I'm going
to wait for like 10 seconds to see if
anyone has the definition of what
informatics actually means to you I'm
just watching it's gathering an
organization information fantastic
so that's precisely it actually let's
see you have given the real definition
so study of how information is collected
stored manipulated classified organized
retrieve visualized it's all too complex
right so and how Clos how does it differ
from
information technology ite rights we all
hear about IT IT experts so how does
informatics actually differ from
information technology information
science computer science so all of them
are all pretty much belong to the same
family right so it's all about data and
how you collect data what kind of data
you collect is immaterial right so you
go shopping and all your you know the
shopper is and everything they're
collecting data as well so pretty much
we're breathing in and breathing out
data today
right so for example we are in the
middle of a pandemic right Kobe 19 how
many publications do you think that we
have actually had on kovat 19 in the
last six months any guesses
how many Pub how many published papers
are out there that's data right so what
do you think how many papers do you
think we have right now on Kobe 19 in
the last six months since we started
getting into this pandemic any guesses
thousand thirty it's actually 30,000 so
you can see the whole entire world is
working so that's data great so that's
what Risa Ilya was talking about
research how do you review literature so
there are like 30,000 publications so
you can see every second we're
generating data now importance to
everyday life can we live with our
informatics today right my personal view
is we cannot everything is about data
anything you do is that so I don't think
we can live without informatics today
right absolutely not
so every day we attach to influenced by
informatics so I'm sure that you all
have a Facebook account Twitter account
these are all one of the most waves in
fact this was actually created by a high
school student so we are all looking at
data all over the place right so there
is scientific data as well coming out of
all of this now so we are actually
living in a data centric world and we
are also we have lots of devices
accusation devices to collect this data
and every single one of us is actually
creating content creating data and the
biggest challenge is how can we actually
meaningfully use this data to get
information from this get the info
mission and how do we actually convert
this to meaningful knowledge and how can
we use this data to use ascii to
advances in sciences in different
disciplines how are we going to use this
data right so of course we are going to
be focused on biological data right so
no escape now all of us need to learn
how to deal with data and data keeps
coming and all of these different tools
and there's lots of different
disciplines that we and we need all of
you took like the collect and
disseminate and actually analyze this
data so the whole goal is for us to take
this data get relevant information from
it and transform that information to
knowledge from knowledge then we can
actually see how best to use the data
and go to the next step right now you
all would have actually realized a lot
of different omics right so there are
different types of omics that's there
and I'm just going to put bioinformatics
in the perspective in this whole world
of informatics so American Medical
Informatics Association has actually
come up with all of these different
omics and we need all of these moments
we need a collaboration between data
from all of these different omics and we
have each one is trying to give us
different levels right so we have
biomedical informatics we have health
informatics we have imaging informatics
we have clinical informatics we have
public health informatics so each one is
dealing with different aspects right so
imaging is based on you know its tissues
and organs and then individual patients
is clinical informatics because you
gather data from patients you then you
have population society Society and then
which is public health which is all of
us are doing you know part of the public
health informatics so but what we are
going to focus on is just one small iota
of this whole world of informatics which
is bio informatics which is deals with
molecular processes proteins DNA RNA and
all of
those things right so that's what we're
going to focus on now what is
bioinformatics right each one of us can
come up with a definition this is like a
50-year old definition it is pretty much
information you have a mouse and you
apply to biology and so you just
bioinformatics it's about computer and
also this was a traditional definition
that was used about 20 years ago right
but now National Institutes of Health
has come up with a definition which is
all very very wordy right at the end of
the day it's about data how we acquired
the data how we store this data so you
organize ar5 analyze and visualize this
is just too complicated for me right
this is just a big if you were to write
an exam to memorize such a big
definition of bioinformatics is just a
lot but I'm gonna in the next several
slides we are going to come up with what
actually is bioinformatics and this'll
fight you everything Ilya was talking
about the whole proteomics and all the
different omics terms right so this is
biological data how do you do
experimentation in the computer that's
why this is called genomics in virtual
genomics which means we're doing all the
experimentations within a computer right
so computer calculations and what comes
out of all of these things now there are
lots of sub disciplines within
bioinformatics because bioinformatics is
an interdisciplinary field because we
need computer scientist we need
biologists we need even economic
economists right now right so we need
it's an interdisciplinary field so there
is a development of new algorithms and
the statistics because the minute you
talk about big data you need statistics
because you want to see if this one
single mutation is actually
statistically significant for us to say
yes this particular mutation causes that
particular disease right and then we
have an analysis and interpretation of
various types of data including
nucleotides amino acid sequences protein
domains and protein structures and how
do we get structures to function and all
of those things and then the development
and implementation of tools because we
can have we can
we can have computer scientists to
develop tools to look at the data and we
also need without tools we cannot even
mine and look under stand that's what
this course you're gonna be learning
about a lot of the sources where there
is data but also you're going to be
using tools to be able to use how do you
use the data without tools
right but we are going to be focusing
just on this aspect of nucleotides and
acid structures and all of that for the
first one we right now is informatics
and new fields what do you think I
really love to ask this question to all
my students and I get different kinds of
answers so I would like to know of
course I wish I had some polling setup
so that because just polls now what do
y'all think is bioinformatics and new
fields or now you can just type s or no
answer into the chat and we'll see we'll
just wait for a second and see okay no
bioinformatics is not a is not an you
feel okay I'm seeing a lot of near no no
no no no no that is actually no okay so
bioinformatics is actually you're right
it's not a new field right so where do
you think it was born
so by informatics is not in your field
but where was bioinformatics actually
born who gave to the small field of
bioinformatics any guesses of which
continent when I went to school it was
seven continents I don't know how many
continents we have today but how do you
Rosalind same in Roslyn Franklin okay
who who where was it born which
continent was it Bonnie thing any
guesses of where my informatics was
actually born Asia okay that would be my
guess as well x-ray crystallography
chromatography of DNA USA okay probably
in Europe
okay so we're covering a lot of
different continents here we forward
Asia you're from Europe Asia is coming
up a lot Europe is coming up a lot UK
yeah sure okay
so Cuba okay good yes actually I'm going
to take someone who just actually
maybe one who made the protein Atlas
okay we are actually coming really
really close that is really true so
bioinformatics is actually I spend a lot
of time on the slide just because it's
really fun to see how people think right
where it was born and yes it was
actually I'm going to get closer to I
think it was funny mala or someone else
said who USA right so I think whoever
said USA it is actually correct so it
was actually born in the US and it was
actually I'm very proud to say that it
was actually born in the Universities I
work in at Georgetown University and I
think Marie Millar you are actually
right it was actually the person who
actually made the protein at last and
who is that person who made the protein
Atlas any guesses so before I introduce
I have to give tribute to this person
Robert lately he was a faculty at
Georgetown he actually died from
Alzheimer's disease and he was the
person who actually discovered the whole
body CT scanner as well and he actually
published a paper in 1959 where he said
he predicted that 50 years or 30 40
years from when he wrote that paper that
we are going to be drowned in data and
we are going to be dealing with
biological data he is the person who
actually hired the person to Georgetown
who actually gave birth to the entire
field of bioinformatics and she is
actually officially now called the
father and the mother of bioinformatics
she was declared the father and mother
mother of bioinformatics by David Lipman
who actually was the director of NCBI
which we will talk about so yes those of
you who said it's a lady yes it is a
lady and she was the one and she
actually came up with this atlas of
protein sequence and structures it is
actually before my time as well
in 1965 right so this is so in 1965
don't even know how many years ago that
was where people used to actually get
sequences published in a book people
used to sequence and send the sequence
to market
and she used to just publish this in a
book and this book was the one that was
actually posted to all the scientists
around the world and that is how they
used to get the protein sequences right
so now what were on her other seminal
contributions is someone said I think it
was very milan who said in atlas and
what and she gave birth at that point
she was a visionary she's considered a
visionary because people who are
visionaries they already think what's
coming 50 years down the road she was
the one who said well we're gonna have a
data explosion so let's create what is
called the data base so she was the
person who first created the protein
database and if any of you are visiting
Washington DC sometime and you visit
judge now I can take hits you actually
the servers and all the books that she
published we still have it because you
know I used to hate history in school
but now I love history and so I've
actually kept all her papers and
everything else as everything was coming
along and she also came up with a single
ledger code for amino acids I'm sure you
all know what single letter amino is
acid letter code is right I'm sure I
don't want to quiz you on that but is
there any recent do you think that she
came up with the single letter amino
acid hold for example glycine GL why is
gene write alanine ala is a right so do
you know why yeah
efficiency but other than the efficiency
of course it's very efficient right
today we look at it and it's extremely
efficient but think in 1960 so why would
she come up with a single letter amino
acid what do you think easy a
representation yes that is definitely
true but other than that you know you
all are in a generation where we have
gigabytes of data in your phone you're
pairing gigabytes of data in your cell
phone so you can do this whole thing in
a cell phone Bray bear back then yeah it
was lack of computation power in the
back then they were talking about
kilobytes of data or even megabytes of
that so they did not have any super
computers so they wanted to make sure
that they don't have enough space so
they are to actually converted that to
single I'm letter amino acid in fact I
learned all these stories from people
who work with her who are actually still
at George Knapp
rate coding storing and
mission insufficient that is correct so
now from that where did we head right
1950s and of course you all know but
Watson and Crick right without what's
meant think we won't be here today and
then we have seen the sequencing without
sequencer we could not have sequenced
anything right so insulin was the first
protein and then FL of course things
started evolving we started seeing lot
and lot more excuse me we started seeing
and then we started seeing polymerase
chain reaction and then and then he
started saying in CBI and then we
started seeing all of these different
databases and it was in 1991 the
official term bioinformatics was grind
and it came up in the literature excuse
me I think I'm screaming a lot here
without of excitement because of all of
you right so then we started seeing all
of these students that was developed and
all of those things and then we started
developing and allowed a lot of
different things started and you can
actually pay attention to here where the
whole genome project initiative was
actually started in the 80s and then and
then the origin of bioinformatics the
first protein sequence reported was that
of insulin in 1956 it consisted of only
151 amino acids and then nearly a decade
later the first nucleic acid sequence
was reported again there is a faculty at
Georgetown movie who actually passed
away two years ago
Jack shirokiya he was the first person
to actually sequence a tRNA when he was
at Princeton so and then what happened
was a major event happened that was that
changed the whole course of human
history
oh I'm seed Elm are you always able to
see the presentation
yes yeah you can see it no okay because
I still see back there not it someone
someone in the chat I just said I'd they
cannot see but try joining him again
leaving and try back okay
so a major event that actually happen
right that actually changed the whole
whole course of human history and you
all know what that is do you all know
what that was that suddenly that's there
was a big event that happened that
actually changed the whole course and
now we are all yes that was correct
Betsy it is a Human Genome Project right
it was a joint British and American
efficient and effort it was a race who
will complete first it was a race just
not whether they have to take drugs but
whether they can actually produce and it
was all the Human Genome Project was
sequenced right stick our life for
actually and so and then the it was a
beginning of data exploration right so
for detailed history you can actually go
here and those of you are very
interested go here so what happened was
this ended it to be the biggest
breakthrough in the field of Informatics
and that has caused the birth of many
many many many disciplines right and so
we are now in a wholesome data tsunami
right big data this is where it actually
started but it did end there we are
still doing a lot of that right and
that's why we are on in a luxury estate
that you can actually do projects you
can actually discover things yourself it
may seem odd but each one of you can
actually find something new because
there's so much data that we still need
a lot of people to actually understand
so now at the conclusion of the human
genome project what happened it actually
created a whole new field of science and
medicine called the genomics right and
now it is completely a whole new field
of genomics virtual genomics where we
can actually okay right and so then what
happened was the human genome was
sequenced and then that didn't end there
then people started going crazy and
started sequencing more and more genomes
right they started sequencing and at the
end of the human genome we had 3.2
billion base pairs of the human genome
right
and people started sequencing more and
more genomes of Drosophila rat and
chicken and mouse and all of those
things so the news when you think that
we are the most important people on this
planet right and we are all trying to
solve diseases we are all trying to cure
diseases when once the human genome when
they declared that it was sequenced why
do you think it is important to actually
sequence the genomes of rats and mouse
and chicken where do we care why do you
think we have to sequence are the
genomes why did people do that any ideas
any guesses yes comparison right that's
right so you want to compare because you
know what we cannot do and to study
evolution that is perfect and to study
evolution but you want to compare
comparative genomics right for example
if I want to find a cure for a disease
even fork overlap test correct so even
if for example Kobe 19 right we are
trying to create like what 20 different
drugs in the world are creating vaccines
trying to do accents you cannot do all
of that in humans right had to do all
the testing we have to first use what
are called the model organisms we want
to test that before we actually tested
in the human right so that's why we have
mouse rats and chickens and everything
else were sequenced so that we can do
comparative genomics of what is
different between humans and them for
various research purposes right to
create a create a disease model
fantastic so that the potential for
drugs of course you guys are really I
love you guys you're very very
interactive this is what gives me more
energy to shout even more right and so
now but what happened is because we have
sequenced so many genomes now and so
many everything else and gave so many
proteomes right now it also comes with a
lot of different challenges right the
challenges that we are actually facing
today is the number of sequences is
exploding we have one hundred and six
billion nucleotides we have more than
six million data from environmental
sequences alone this we are not even I'm
not even going to talk about this unless
one of you is interested I can talk
about this later and then we have lots
of data in
in uniprot knowledge face which we're
going to be talking about and you will
have lots of hands-on experience with
uniprot and then from the up sequences
we have domains we have
three-dimensional structures we have
protein families we have clusters of our
thatha's groups and all of those things
this is just we are just talking about
proteins in DNA I'm not even talking
about other data sources like medical
electronic health records medical
records and any of those things that's
going to be beyond the scope for this
lecture so I'm not even going to talk
about those things right and now how are
we going to deal with all of this data
explosion right all of this data
explosion the first thing you want to do
is collect this data and create
databases so that you and me actually
can get access to this data and from
that data we can you and me can look and
search for things we can we can see how
to extract knowledge from these
databases and all of this that is used
in genome analysis right so these are
all the molecular biology databases you
know I have been in the business of
bioinformatics mode for more than 10-15
years one thing that's actually always
been challenging to me is what is the
challenge let me ask you the question
what do you think is the biggest
challenge that we are all facing or you
are facing for example you want to look
at a protein you want to look at
something you have a research question
what do you think is the biggest
challenge that we're actually facing
today what do you think as as users you
know what are the challenges the
challenges sudden change in the field
extract yes yes all of this is correct
challenging so all of this is correct
storage computational power yes all of
these are big challenges we're facing
today excuse me so but the biggest
challenge you know when I'm facing our I
face I don't know where to go I just
don't know where to go and I just don't
know which database is reliable which
database is not reliable I just don't
even know where to go to get this data
right as a new user to bioinformatics
where to find the data is actually the
biggest challenge so what happened was
data managing that is correct so what
has happened is
just at NIH what they did was yes they
said well you know what I want to give
the community to for them to say okay
this database is this bad a database is
not good and all of those things so they
came up with a publication January 1st
of every single year they publish a
paper and I think I've given that paper
to you and you will receive it and that
tells you which data to which database
to go to which database is there and how
many databases are there like thousands
of databases right now but you can go to
that publication and look up if a
protein what are the rest of different
databases that are there that is that
are actually reliable that are curated
which means it's actually manually
someone has validated the data and all
of those fun stuff right so this whole
thing is actually given all of this data
and sequencing and all of this data data
has actually given birth to a ohms and
ohmic era in biology right so I'm sure
all of you know about central dogma of
molecular biology right I'm not going to
go and talk to you about it because I'm
sure all of you have heard about this or
all if you have learned about this right
so what it is is from DNA to RNA RNA to
protein and then protein to structures
structure to function that was pretty
much the central dogma and pretty much
of course there was a world before the
DNA took over there was a world that was
called the RNA world which I believe in
but anyway this is beyond the scope for
this week or course just wanted to put
it out there right now each one of this
aspects of the central dogma has created
an ohmic term right so DNA study of DNA
what is that ohmic term that corresponds
to DNA anyone any guesses what is this
called
in terms of omics if you want to convert
this to omics what is this called
what is this field of studying DNA
genomics fantastic you guys are really
smart and then RNA what is it called
transcriptomics yes exactly and then
proteins is proteomics right and then
structure is something I coined myself
because they didn't come up with an
ohmic term and I'm a structural
biologist by training so I
came up at structural mix and now it's
beginning to actually get used in
applicable aces and then at the end of
the day all of us are trying to figure
out the functions of each one of these
right so then I came up to functions and
then how do you understand the function
we have to look at pathways in the
protein which which gene is implicated
in which pathway and which metabolics
are involved because at the end of the
day every cell we look at metabolites
that the reactions are producing so it
has created her whole feel of
metabolomics so already you can see the
entire central dogma is actually
transformed into biome so this is the
what I call is the dogma of
bioinformatics right so this is all the
data and as Helia said fine biotech is
an outstanding platform that I've never
seen any other platform that actually
puts everything in one place pretty much
you can do genomics transcriptomics
proteomics metabolomics pretty much you
can do everything in one platform right
so thanks Julia and fine PI that for
providing us with that right so then we
have all of this ohmic terms of course
there are lots of lots of I mean
officially there are about more than
hundred and sixty-eight or 200 different
ohmic temps right so now you can
actually what I'm trying to drive at is
this is actually explosion of data
coming from each one of this particular
ohmic terms right and then what is
missing in this list of structure omics
which I took the liberty of adding right
so at the end of the day each one of
these omics
is actually the one that is generating
data pulling us into the era of big data
and each one of this is the data that
we're gonna use for research purposes to
discover your whatever question that you
may actually have right so this is all
what we are actually looking at now I
gave you a formal definition of
bioinformatics just about 20 minutes ago
I gave you a formal definition but with
all of this data with all of this ohmic
data I came up with my own definition of
bioinformatics and I think the
definition of my informatics is pretty
much its incorporation of all of these
different omec jumps right
I could only fit so many ohmic terms in
this but there are lot more ohmic terms
right so each one of this actually is
generating
right so that is where all of this data
from is right how far by informatics has
actually come by and fluoride exists it
has actually come a very long way so by
end of this week you're actually going
to you know at the last lecture who's
actually actually an expert who's coming
from National Center for Biotechnology
information and CBI he actually is part
of this whole data thing so he is going
to give you all the applications of my
informatics and actually you will be
actually seeing how far we have come and
actually we have come a very long way
right so I will leave it at that for now
so that there is a surprise for you
right so now by informatics of course I
think we I don't want you you know we
may be running out of time so I don't
want to like spend too much time on this
so bioinformatics anyone any quick
guesses of filling this boxes I know
this is like you know I wish we had the
wheel of fortune so we can actually you
know come in intervention information
anomic term actually we are very getting
very very close I'm G now makes some
where there so the terms is there o mix
is there in this and I'm just going to
give you the answer so it is actually
the integration of all the victims
rights that that is my definition of
bioinformatics I'm not sure if it makes
sense to you each of us can come up with
our own definition of bioinformatics but
this is the definition of my informatics
right so now what is what is all about
it's all about sequences why is sequence
analysis very important right we have
lots of millions and millions of
sequences in public databases like NCBI
and we have lot more in propriety
databases as well and in locked up in
all of these sequences is a huge amount
of structural and function and
evolutionary information which is what
you're going to learn in the next few
days of how are we going to get just
from a single sequence how are we going
to get extract the information about
structures how are we going to able we
are going to extract it from it about
functions and how are we going to look
back to evolution and how is all of this
relevant and how is it going to be
useful today
right so they're highly valuable
resources right nothing in biology is
without sequence analysis today right so
they're highly highly
valuable resources and we have huge
amount of informations and we are going
to moving forward just focus on sequence
analysis of proteins and all of those
things so what is there in a sequence
what do we have in a sequence is
actually we have it says you know just
based on alignments we can figure out if
something is conserved or not why is
this important I'm going to talk to you
about that in in in the coming day or
two why is this relevant why do we need
alignments what is there in a stress so
in this sequence of protein you have all
the information that you need to fold
this protein and actually to figure out
what regions of this protein are
actually important so in a sense
everything that you need to know is
actually hidden in this particular
primary sequence right how are we able
to get that information meaningfully to
understand the functions of proteins and
understand how just one single mutation
in this particular sequence is actually
causing a disease right so those are the
things that we will actually be learning
right now I'm just going to now take you
into the whole world of data right I'm
going to tell you about all the
different projects and big from where it
started the human genome project and
where are we right now and what have we
learned from each one of these projects
and how can we actually use them in
order to be able to move forward right
so that is what we're going to learn so
at the end of the day what a disease
what is disease diseases or
manifestation of something that's
actually gone wrong in a protein or a
gene right so when something goes wrong
in a protein or a gene that doesn't work
properly and so that manifests itself
which is what we call diseases right now
the pieces that are all inside of each
one of us that makes who we are is we
have genomes and we have the DNA from
the genomes and then we have the genes
and then we have the proteins right at
the end of the day each one of this is
actually very very important now if I
were to ask you a question but I'm going
to reserve it for a later time is are
you and me the same are you and me
identical you and me do we have
identical DNA right then the problem is
less complicated right because all our
DNA is identical right is that the case
you're gonna you're gonna talk about it
right now the Human Genome Project yeah
that is true no that's right snips
absolutely
you're all getting yes absolutely we are
gonna get to that that's exactly what to
all look that you're you're not putting
in the chart is what we're gonna be
talking about in the next 30 minutes or
so
the human genome project has transformed
the baby thinkable diseases correct so
genetics 101 so we knew about 20-30
years ago so DNA this is the dogma that
we just talked about replication then we
have transcription then we have
translation into proteins and we know
proteins are the life forms right and we
have this is pretty much amino acids
folds into three-dimensional structures
and that is where we get functions right
and we have we mapped these two pathways
then structures genome some so we say
from genotype to phenotype right so from
DNA to proteins genotype to phenotype
this is what we have learned at least I
learned in school right of course you're
all learning something new you're very
lucky I really wish I was reborn today
because there's so much I can learn
today that I didn't learn during my
times right now how do you classify
these diseases right so single gene
disorders so monogenic diseases right
sickle cell anemia all of you heard of
sickle cell anemia I'm pretty sure right
so monogenic diseases this is where we
knew how to deal with this for the last
20-30 years right
so what is monogenic there's only a
mutation in one just one gene so it's
easy you just fix the gene
right now we have CRISPR cast nine and
we have everything if you have all the
tools to fix this right away right so
someone asked me earlier whether we are
there yet we are there almost we are
able to fix these things right I'll be
able to do that of course that's a
complicated story now complex disorders
is polygenic diseases which means there
are more than one mutations more than
one calling orphism
so it becomes very very complex trait
Alzheimer's is a very complex disease
and then chromosomal disorders genomic
disorders for example Down syndrome this
something will it be possible to get
these slides at the end of the class you
will get the recording of the lecture a
celia said yes and so chromosomal
disorders genomic disorders Down
syndrome for example Down syndrome is
been there for more than twenty years we
exactly know how to detect Down syndrome
and someone is pregnant during the
pregnancy we already can actually
predict that they're going to have that
you know a child with Down syndrome so
these are all the diseases that we
actually know pretty well right and now
there are lots of other diseases
environmental infectious diseases we are
right now in the middle of a pandemic
right for with nineteen is an infectious
disease and by now each one of you know
how complex that is right and it does
require us us of course it's it's a
totally different story and and I am
sure Lilia is gonna talk about it and
week two right and then excuse me I but
wholly caused by these diseases these
monogenic diseases are extra missing
chromosome and all of these things we
know very well about and we know how to
treat them we know how to detect them we
know how to deal with all of these
things right so these are all of course
I wouldn't say that we have a cure for
everything we have
we know how to detect these are all
single mutations in the gene and I'm
gonna be talking to you about sickle
cell anemia tomorrow when I talk about
how this one single mutation imagine
just one base change in your entire gene
is changed and that is leading to your
disease Y right that's what we're gonna
talk about tomorrow right
and then these conditions are of great
importance to individuals and families
that have them but even when added
together they're relatively rare and
most people directly affected very you
know only very few people are directly
affected so genetics you know that's
played a very small role in health care
I'm talking about well before the whole
explosion of it that it made very
minimal role because we knew only about
a certain diseases monogenic diseases
and all of those things right now again
so all of this I'm doing this is just a
summary these are all the different
diseases
this is monogenic diseases right a
single mutations and of course for your
projects that you will do be able you
know we will talk about some of these
that you can actually
on these diseases and look for beyond of
all of those things now what happened
this was all oh I call it the old
genetics right what is the new genetics
this is a result of the human genome
product right it comes largely from the
knowledge emanating from the human
genome project
genetics the future is now right so now
what have you learned about the human
genome project what we have actually
learned is that it's complex
it has 3.2 billion base pair base pairs
and we also have 16,000 base pairs also
in the mitochondrion and then what
happened was it is it was actually as I
said earlier it was initiated in 1990
and then the complete draft of the human
genome was actually it came about and it
was originally planned for 2005 and then
they finished two years ahead of time
and the story I hear is that they ran
out of money but do we have do we know
everything we need to know about the
human genome today what is your guess so
here I'm telling you here that the human
genome is actually sequenced which means
we should know every single gene in the
human body we should know about every
single gene in the human body that means
we should be solving the diseases like
just like that right but a B no not at
all that is the true answer we don't we
are still trying to understand in fact
there are that is one chromosome
chromosome six I believe we still
actually don't have the best sequence of
chromosomes think so we are still
sequencing sequencing to get a better
drug but we do I'm simply having said
that we still know a lot about the human
genome right so now these are human
genome projects right so this is a
laboratory Mouse it has 20 to 21
thousand genes look at this something
that fascinated me was a fruit fly right
and you know and all of these things I
draw a roundworm it's just a small worm
that you step on as you walk you won't
even know that you step on as you walk
right it has 13,000 cheese right and I'm
sure you all think that and agree with
me that you get much complex than a
single world is a small worm right and
and we are complex right so now what do
you all think how many genes do you
think we actually have what does your
will it be a B C or D very quick I know
that you know we don't have much time to
play around with it D okay 10,000 genes
we have 10,000 some people say I wish we
had pooling because then we would
immediately know what all of you are
saying so a lot of people are saying B
and some are saying C some are actually
saying D yes so there is quite honestly
there is truth to B and C we initially
thought because the worms genome came
about it had about 30,000 genes and just
imagine a woman a human we thought oh my
god we're gonna have 50,000 genes when
people started sequencing the human
genome in the 80s we the prediction was
we can have 50,000 genes based on
whatever we knew about other organisms
but now then as we started sequencing we
said okay it's going to be around 35 but
you know what after sequencing majority
of you who said B or actually because we
actually do have anywhere between 20 to
21 thousand genes and why am I saying
anywhere between 20 I'm not able to give
you a full figure because we still are
sequencing some of the chromosomes are
very complex so we still don't know but
if we know for a fact that we are going
to only somewhere between 20 and 21
thousand that means we are not that
complex right if you think about it you
know that at that complex but we're
still complex and I will tell you where
this complexity is actually coming from
right so we have and look at this human
has 20,000 and we have exactly the same
number of genes as a mouse and I'll be
the same as a mouse a mouse is amongst
human is a human right we are not but
I'm gonna tell you where this complexity
of the human genome is actually coming
from right so now virtually all diseases
except trauma actually have a genetic
component right this is the new genetics
now because of all the Human Genome
Project look at here in 2007 right after
we actually saw the human before the
human genome project we knew very little
about some of the genes implicated in
type 2 diabetes and then PPR in cancers
and stuff like that well then we started
slowly with a with the human genome we
started seeing more and more and more
and by 2007 we actually identified
a lot of different genes implicated in
different diseases and we also actually
lot more a lot more I'm not going to
spend too much time on this but I'm just
forced forwarding to today 2020 with all
of the data that we have I'm just going
to rely only on uniprot because we're
going to be doing this hands-on when
we're doing the hands-on session right
so now we I really like this right so
the future is now well they're really
real disease gene please stand up so we
are almost there we're from nature a lot
of not majority of the diseases I will
say a lot of diseases we actually know
what are the genes that are involved in
what are the genes that are implicated
in but do we have a cure for those
diseases of course not right we need
your house to actually do all the
projects that you have to do and then
figure out and that's where the whole
world is involved in right to find cure
for all of these diseases but we
actually at least know what is causing
these diseases that's a first step right
so we can actually then move to the next
step so now how many curated genes do
you think we have identified right I
told you that with before human genome
we just had a few genes that we knew but
now like after like 1517 years what do
you think reach how many do we actually
have right so I don't know if people are
actually double yes or D 2,000 genes
okay so a majority of you are actually
saying d let's see if that does the
right answer whoops sorry
maybe see okay we can go around so I'm
going to give you so C and D actually
are not the correct answers so it is
actually we are going to actually when
you're doing the uniprot hands-on I'm
going to show you where to get this
number from right so we actually kind of
I'm gonna say roughly approximately I
should say that we have four thousand
five hundred genes right there come
along we're done better than you think
we have done right then from genes to
proteins right so now this is my last
question to you right then we will speed
them and actually you know try to finish
but I also want to mention that I have a
whole week with you so if I'm not able
to complete something today I will take
we'll take on because we last about
first 30 minutes in the introduction
today so I'm not sure if I'll be able to
complete everything that I'd planned for
so I will apologize
your head if you're not able to because
I like to do things slowly so that
things are not speed up but we will get
you know we'll get to all of those yes
everybody has a heard of me said
fantastic you know I didn't even have to
ask you yes we have hundred thousand so
I'm sure all of you know and you've been
taught that one gene codes for one
protein correct so I told you that there
are only 20,000 genes in the human and
so which means we should have only
20,000 protein products right where is
this hundred thousand this is roughly
hundred thousand I should I actually
tell you that this is not the number
this is our pleased and 100,000 protein
product where do you think this is
actually coming from this number because
I'm telling you one gene codes for one
protein but then I'm giving you this
whole huge figure of protein products
where is this yes exactly so paradox is
correct it is alternating and Karina yes
it is coming from alternative splicing
and I'm going to show you all of this
when we do the hands-on right where is
this coming you know we learned a lot of
cool things from the human genome
project we have lot fewer fewer genes to
deal with and only about 1.5 percent of
the human genome is involved in coding
right only 1.5 person imagine out of 100
percent of the human genome only 1.5
percent is actually coding for proteins
right what is the reminder of the 98.5%
right and do you all know what that was
actually called the whole one point 98.5
percent of the genome that doesn't code
for proteins do you know what that was
actually called before the whole before
2013 I would say I'm just going to give
you the answer now heterochromatin yes
someone said Karina you're right jump
DNA that was what it was all called junk
can you believe that it was all called
chunk and now we have written a eulogy
to judge the junk DNA right I'm going to
tell you what that is all about so what
have we learned we have learned that you
are very different from a mouse although
we have the same number of genes with a
mouse because you know what we have lots
of change the differences thank God we
have they are different from a mouse
correct so we are different but yet we
do use Mouse as a model because we are
similar in many aspects so we are able
to
use mouse and rat and chicken as models
to study diseases but then some of them
fail right I'm sure you've heard of lots
of drugs that come to clinical trials
they even come to clinical trial phase
three and then they fail right because
we're still trying to learn because why
of course drugs why they fail that's
completely a different story and that
will take me a week to actually talk to
you about don't design and everything
else that's beyond the scope for this
course and who is our closest relative
what do you think who is our course yeah
not trained yeah a lot of people you're
very interactive I love this group what
who's our closest relative do you think
apes primates monkey actually chimp is
our closest relative here actually about
ninety six and you know what some of the
things that chimp has we don't have I
wish we had what the chimp has some of
the genes that the chimp has that we
don't know and I'm thankful for some of
the genes we have that the chimp doesn't
have so that we are able to talk Jim
doesn't have Fox at Fox p2 which is for
speech I'm glad and we have a sixth
sense you know and of course the chimp
has some you know some caspases that
could have prevented us from getting
Alzheimer's but we have lost it so you
know there are good good differences
there in chimp on us and how close are
we among ourselves we're actually almost
but this number changes between ninety
nine point five to ninety nine point
nine but all it says is your knee
thankfully we are all very close to each
other but we is still very very
different from each other
right so of course the Human Genome
Project actually came up with a lot a
lot of promises the biggest promise it
came up with was they are going to solve
diseases normal diseases end of CCC's
but we are fifteen fifteen years after
we still have lots to learn right we
still haven't solved a lot of diseases
become a long way then you know the
whole NIH said you know what we thought
that you know we with the Human Genome
Project variable to solve all diseases
but then they realized you know what to
people to patients even with let's go
with 19 right to people don't have the
same symptoms some react better to some
drugs than others we still don't have a
drug but some even some diseases in
right some chemotherapeutic regiments
working in one patient with the same
disease same cancer same stage it
doesn't work in another why right we are
similar but we are significantly
different as well right so there is all
this so the NIH who funded the human
genome project and the whole world was
working on it and all of those things
yes all of these things and then what
happened was what is okay so what is all
of these differences where is all of
this differences coming from when I'm
telling you that we are or 99.5% similar
right where is all this difference so we
did not know at that point what this so
then what happened people react
different to drugs yes polymorphism Wow
that is still a lot yes
snip we have snips and all of those
things stalks the city and all of those
things like this led nih to say you know
what we are not we are looking at
something and we are missing a whole
bunch we're just looking at 1.5 percent
of the genome we're just looking at the
genes or there'll be a 99.5% similar but
then drugs in one does not work in
another so what is happening so then
what happened was and I ate said well
let's go and look at what is that is
causing that's different between us
which is the whole hapmap project the
whole mapping of polymorphism single
nucleotide polymorphisms so you can see
we started here we finished here but we
still don't have a lot of answers we
have more questions that came out of
this but not many answers so then we
said okay let's go and figure out the
different the point five percent or 0.7
percent that is actually different
between all of us right now the hapmap
project you're not so and of course they
came up with other database generating
projects genome-wide Association studies
thousand genome project million project
and of course but the list goes on and
on and on where we have drowning in the
era of this is where all the big data
this is what is big data all about right
so there's so much of volume of all of
this data so now what does half my
project have my project excuse me is is
charting genetic variation between us
excuse me what is not what is common
between you but what is different
between you and me right so mutation and
variation right so those are two
different things
and I'm going to talk to you about that
tomorrow and so we just see
polymorphisms right so and how can have
my project help us understand diseases
and why some respond and others do not
respond to the same therapy right so
this is the cause of human diversity how
would you test the human diversity is
single nucleotide polymorphisms look
look for correlation between snips and
some of those phenotypes so what are
snips snips are defined a single base
change in your DNA just one change right
how scary can it be we are sequencing
sequencing right and we are looking for
just one small base change so how can
you say that if something is actually an
error in sequencing and you find a
difference right and then you say oh my
god this is different and can you say
that yes this is different and they can
have a disease now that's why of course
our lilius horses you when you take you
will see you know all these reads and
how many times we have the sequence and
we have to look at the depth then you
have to do all of those things right so
we are thankfully we have our own ways
of figuring out if that snip is actually
real trustable and what population
actually has that's not right so now
this facts about snips are they're very
common in human population between any
two people there's an average of one
snip in every thousand bases and you
just imagine if every single difference
in a snip is going to cause a disease
each one of us is going to be walking
around with thousands of different
diseases right but that's not the case
we're all healthy right so which means
majority of these snips that actually
don't do anything they don't cause but
there are some snaps that actually cause
a disease which means if this under snip
is actually if so happens to be close to
a gene that is important in regulation
or if the snip is as in a place where it
changes the amino acid a coding region
of the genome then it is not going to be
tolerated right so we are going to be
talking about some of those then I
importance of these snips assign alleles
of health related genes they are
genetic markers too right now they're
fast to get these genotyping that's what
it's called and then it's genetic
Association studies so that one
population of people may actually have
some snips one population may have
different snips right so those are the
differences between ethnic populations
so as you can see the complexity is
going more and more why one drug works
in one person one drug does not work in
another person why this drug given to an
Asian what's differently from you know
our population Hispanics of Caucasians
so you can see this is where the answer
lies
and we are trying to unlock this answer
right now
a map of the thing just imagine it has
given rise to one point four two million
polymorphisms right this ACMA
so you can already imagine how many
databases are created just with this
just and how many people in the world
can actually work with just this snip
dad I actually work with some data right
to figure out the difference is even
with Co but people are trying to figure
out why some Asians are not having you
know symptoms and why you know all of
those different things polymorphisms why
some people are having higher mortality
how some people are having more severe
disease so my guess is they probably
have polymorphisms and there is - and
other genes that is giving them right
I'm actually looking at those I don't
have answers but we are all looking at
these things now say slick snips can
lead to altered protein sequence and so
when a snip actually changes the actor
line amino acid then it I can actually
cause a disease right
so sickle cell mutations also or
actually delete area snips right so
they're inherited Mendelian genetic
disorders most of these deleted
variations affect the functions of the
protein and sickle cell anemia we're
going to talk about this why it is all
at the end of the day it is all answers
to everything is actually in the
three-dimensional structure of proteins
which is what we're going to be talking
about tomorrow see for example in sickle
cell anemia there's only one mutation
right from a glutamic acid show really
so it is in this position and look at
the changes in the structure with just
one position this
just visual you can just see how the
Gila cesare rearranging and completely
things look very different right so just
one mutation can actually cause a large
change in the three-dimensional
structure and three-dimensional
structures is very integral to
understanding functions without
structures you can understand functions
right so now what has happened with all
of these snips is people started
creating sequence of genomes of large
populations and they're comparing all of
these so all the people who have similar
snips could actually be the same all the
people who have different snips and
there are so many examples of how a snip
actually can actually work as a
biomarker in one population ISM in one
population it may cause it may be
detrimental another population it may
actually be protective in another
population it may actually that's nick
may not even affect that population so
we're learning a lot about this so like
your facebook profiles that each one of
you actually probably have so we can
actually create create profiles by
grouping people with similar things
right and then this is actually very
easily it can easily be used for the
classes purposes right so II genome of
each individual contains the snakes that
matter and people can be grouped based
on snake profiles and snip profiles is
very very important in identifying
responses to drug therapy for example
one example is albuterol is an inhaler
that is given for people with asthma so
depending on what polymorphism people
have albuterol may actually work for
that people are that person for asthma
or may not actually work so people are
actually looking at the snip profiles
right now to figure out which drug will
work which drug may not work then so
this is actually a very very powerful
tool that we are all actually looking
into and there are lots of correlations
that will emerge do we know about
everything probably not but we are we
are getting there we are actually
learning more at least we know that it's
actually very very important and one
case study that's actually being used
and I know it is actually being used at
least in Canada and in some clinics
where they test for warfare it right
warfarin is you know it is a most widely
prescribed anti
by deleting that is that is it is used
for preventing thrombolytic clots
electrons so anyone who's in a hospital
going through surgeries actually they're
given just to avoid that they actually
develop electrons right so it's actually
very important so actually if you don't
give the right dosage of a drug it
actually can impact you in many
different ways which is what we're
finding and you have to look into the
you know ethnic it where they are where
they belong and what is their age and
everything else right second most
important and it's also it can into
simply get an adverse drug reaction as
well right so personalized warfare in
doesn't people have found me this is
actually being used right now this is an
example that is actually being used so
they found snips that actually define
what dosage to give someone and they
found the snips to figure that out
whether even what funnel is even going
to work in this for work in that
particular agent I know for ever for a
fact that Asians at least people of
Indian origin actually need mass much
less dosage of this and so you have to
be very careful and so physicians even
if they're they're all in clinical
trials right now and some some clinics
already actually use it in Canada I know
that for a fact right so so you actually
snips are very important so we have
identified a lot of different snaps
right so the lots of different snips
that have been identified and in fact
there is a slit pedia that has been
created you can actually go and look at
snippy dia to figure out which
polymorphism is actually working in
something and statins for example it's
given and all of those things like
tamoxifen and all of those different
things this is just an example to show
you how important this is now this whole
project hapmap has led to another whole
fear the pharmacogenomics or the other
term that is constantly being used as
personalized medicine and I'm sure
you've all heard rate one size does not
fit all right one size does not fit all
so what works and one person does not
work it's not surprising and so this all
this work on hapmap actually led to more
gene a whole field of pharmacogenomics
how you use individuals genetic proof
to predict responses to draw certain
drugs and clinical goal is to enable
drug treatment decisions and genetic
tests are already available in years for
some of these diseases pharmacogenomics
has actually the potential to
revolutionize how drugs are being
developed and prescribed and of course a
big part of it is also how do we do drug
repurposing right even when one size
does not fit all anyway that's a topic
for another day and of course excuse me
and also the last project of course I'm
going to talk to you about is the input
project encyclopedia of DNA elements so
I think we discussed earlier right the
98.5% are for genome that used to be
called junk DNA excuse me yes in
biochemistry textbook if you're all
familiar with biochemistry textbook
Lenin sure if you look in maybe version
edition three and two and four in fact
and when I studied biochemistry
all of this was actually called the junk
DNA we didn't we didn't even hear about
it all that we cared about is this one
point five percent of the human genome
that codes for just proteins like coding
region but then once we didn't get
answers from half map right hapmap
answered a lot of questions but also you
know what it was not actually answering
a lot of different questions that we had
so then we said okay you know what
finally we have to invest time in
looking at this 98.5% maybe there is
some clue there that is actually more
important than we ever thought
right so the encode project when it was
completed oh my god you can imagine
there were like 6,000 to 7,000
publications within a month week when
teary I am still you know still reading
which was in 2013 what it said was it
rise eulogy to junk DNA so there is no
more concept of junk DNA people are
going to be offended if you say oh it's
junk it's not chant quite honestly this
region of the genome is actually the one
that is more important or equally
important than all the coding Riebe cuz
you know why it actually carries the
keys to regulation
these proteins so the G that non-coding
region actually holds keys to the coding
region can you believe that so it as if
they've identified a lot and lot of
regulatory elements that regulate the
functions of all of the genes that we
thought was the most important so which
means what does this tell you this tells
you that actually every part of your
human genome is actually important there
is nothing in your genome that is
actually not important so which means
even you guys will have a lifetime of
work to do to uncover all of this and
I'm not sure what is coming next of
course l lots of other projects coming
next but we still have a whole hands and
you can see your whole field of
Informatics how is it exploded just in
15 years and look at where we are today
so these are all all of these things
right so then the genome-wide
Association study which is one of my
favorite studies that I use it a lot is
how the polymorphisms differ between
different ethnic populations right how
does this drug work in a European
population why is it not working in
Asian population right and why is all of
these things or whatever it is right so
I'm not sure if I should be shot are you
actually keeping track of the questions
in the chat by any chance so that we can
actually get back to answering those
questions
yeah so then I can actually spell the
last in ten minutes maybe to just kind
of you know summarize and answer all
those questions sure so there too
because you know since I lost time in
the beginning I just need to make sure I
actually am able to end in I apologize
all if they're all a few people that you
know your question your questions are
coming in but I'm gonna answer I will
answer those questions for sure I just
hold on to those questions so
genome-wide association studies it
actually enables a comparison of genetic
variations between different ethnic
populations right now that is actually a
big thing and if there is a catalog that
we can just download to a computer and
actually analyze there that has actually
come up at all mapped a lot and lot of
snips that differ between different
populations
actually and then it is actually very
good that you can actually you know
compare those snips and figure out oh my
goodness this snip is found in European
population which means you know what
this drug is not going to work so if
this is actually going to help us a lot
initially but we are still trying to
figure this out you know why because
majority of the snips that are coming
out of genome-wide Association studies
are actually in the intronic region in
the non-coding region so we are still
trying to make sense of these snips but
there are lots of tools that have been
developed and so but this is still very
useful right there are still lots of
Sims that we are actually so the benefit
is it has actually expanded our
understanding of diseases it simplified
the process of finding small variations
and it has actually discovered numerous
diseases snips and also the genes right
and will definitely help in connecting a
lot of different dots for us right so
Gina white population and I believe
there are like about lots of lots of
different studies that have come up and
now there is genome-wide Association
studies with phobic patients and I just
got a glimpse small little glimpse of
what it's looking like it's still not
publicly available and also you probably
all heard also that some populations are
affected more than others of course we
already know that people who have
comorbidity conditions like hypertension
and high cholesterol and all of those
things are at a higher risk than you
know other people right so that we
already know that age is a factor people
with comorbidities like hypertension and
cholesterol high cholesterol and you
know cardiovascular diseases or anything
else if you have conditions that means
you went to you're more vulnerable and
actually it is can be mortality is
probably higher in this population right
of course we're also learning other
things and of course one of the major
factors which is something that I am
looking into is as well one of the thing
is that a lot of people there is a
the problem with blood coagulation
pathway so you are people are seeing a
lot of clotting even in young younger
people even in people with who are in
the thirties and you know thirties and
younger than thirties people are seeing
a lot of different clotting and all of
those things but all of this is
something that we are already you know
we are seeing all of this but yet there
are some things that we are seeing at
least in the u.s. I'm not looking at
other countries in detail is there is a
higher you know cases and higher
mortality rates among African American
population in the u.s. at least so it is
like oh why is that happening is because
of course one is of coz there a lot of
them are frontline workers essentially
bookerson all of those things but in
spite of that they also are at a higher
risk for high cholesterol and
hypertension and cardiovascular diseases
but also there are some polymorphisms in
some of their genes that I'm actually
putting together of course I can't
present it yet because I'm just putting
you up the story but I just want to
drive to you the fact this these
genome-wide Association areas are
extremely remarkably useful for
understanding the differences between
different ethnic populations right now
there are lots of 100k projects and all
of those things right so now all the
diseases in jiva's of course I'm not
update that I have not updated this but
there are a lot more diseases like there
are like 15 thousand diseases discuss
right now and there are like thousands
of genes and thousands of snips that the
genome-wide Association studies have
identified in fact there are some
diseases where the clues for those
diseases came from genome-wide
Association studies for example
inflammatory bowel disease for many
decades we when they were thinking of
there is only one polymorphism in one
particular gene not two but then now we
are learning that it's just not bad but
we're also learning that this
genome-wide Association study says
actually uncovered a lot of low sigh in
inflammatory bowel disease there are a
lot of diseases that actually a
genome-wide Association so we are as you
can see from the very start from the
Human Genome Project to have my project
to a whole project you know what
Association studies we're actually
gathered a lot of data and we actually
have
a lot of knowledge from all of those
things I'll be still there yet
but right now there's too much data we
have not even looked at it to figure out
whether we still need other things there
is one other thing that we are learning
right now which is the next phase and
the next wave that I'm not going to be
talking about about that you all know
there is something that's missing from
all my slides there is one project
that's actually become very integral
right now we are actually missing I'm
not talking about it but it's actually
very very important is there do you see
anything that I'm missing I'm not sure
any guesses of some things that I'm
actually missing maybe earlier maybe
talking about it next week
yeah actually a yeah there are lots of
other genome projects that is true UK
has a huge project and even here we are
having a 1 million project we're having
lots of different sequencing projects
that is true yes actually it's a very
good question and I'm going to address
you I'm not sure if I'm saying yeah very
very did the term big data come from yes
I'm not actually sure if I can answer
your question about in literature where
the term so there is this thing called V
for velocity velocity and volume and
what is the other way I'm missing all of
the other ways so there are like four
ways they defined one of the companies
actually that says that this is actually
v4 which is the volume based on volume
based on whatever it is and I think yeah
variability Thank You Leah so
variability so this v4 is the one that
actually said and I think I don't even
remember I don't know if alia knows the
answer to this question in terms of when
did a big dumb baked ham come into the
literature so I think because everything
was so big I think people just started
using big I don't know exactly the
answer but it's actually a fantastic
question I have never been asked this
question I don't know if Helia do you
have an answer to that question whether
the whole concept of who started you
saying I think it is one of those
companies that actually who defined a v4
but I
actually we will so Ilyas gonna talk
about it and also I will actually you
know that is my homework for me today I
will I will see if I can find that
answer and I'll share it with you or
tomorrow if you're gonna be that
tomorrow just ask me the question again
right okay so what is missing in all of
those is microbiome right microbiome is
the one that we are missing in this and
I think Helia is going to be talking
about this so that is another new face
that we're all in that it's the microbes
that actually control us not all of
these things because we have more number
of genes from the microbes then our own
whom your human gene which means they
are actually taking over all of this
stuff right you would think that they we
have like more than three times more
number of genes and then we have so so
this is all a summary of all of this
data that we actually have and then what
is the future as you can see the future
of genomics which is already the future
right now is to go to a physician what
are they going to do they're going to
actually do all of this informatica
analysis on you to figure out a pattern
right I'll be there reacts today
I think that's recess when I gave this
talk ten years ago I said we're not
there yet we will get there yet get
there but in 10-year now I'm looking
back and I'm yes actually we are already
there because the several of physicians
actually do sequence sequencing and
that's why even all the Cobie data is
there for you to analyze next week it's
very exciting we have lots of data from
patient samples we have a lot of
clinical data and see maybe a lot a lot
of sequencing data and it is every
single physicians office I have they all
have sequencing data in their freezers
for people like you who are going to
train get trained in bioinformatics are
going to be do are going to have good
jobs because we really need informations
we don't have that many implementations
to actually who know how to analyze this
all of this data and thanks to companies
like Brian Wright where they're creating
platforms for us to make our life much
easier to actually mind all of this data
create projects and all of those things
right so this is going to be the future
of all of these things because we know
more specific information because of all
of this we can actually diagnose more
precisely in fact there is a whole
consortium of
rare diseases right so people who have
rare diseases who did not have a
diagnosis 20 years ago now they actually
can have a diagnosis and I know of
personally I know this person big
scientists at NIH was actually doing
this project of diagnosing people who
where who said that oh there is no
diagnosis we don't know what this is I
have no idea what this is there is no
diagnosis now we are able to there's a
whole range assistance Asha
right select specific treatment their
best fits and also predict risks before
the symptoms occur you can actually
manage diseases more effectively and of
course you can actually you know what
target medication specifically the whole
concept of personalized medicine provide
earlier treatment actually you know take
preventive actions eliminate unnecessary
treatments actually and you know provide
better timings for all of those things
and I just treatments to changes in all
that so in this provide earlier
treatment take preventive actions and
actually even save healthcare dollars
right and there's one example I'm going
to give you is I'm not sure how many of
you actually have heard of the drug
called tamoxifen which is something that
I put it in my earlier slides as
something baby have the polymorphisms
for have you all anyone know what
tamoxifen is have you heard of the term
ox drug tamoxifen yes I see yes no you
know a lot of knows some is okay so
those of you actually say yes can you
tell me what some of you say yes so can
you tell me what what it is what what
the drug is used for cancer that's
correct so the drug is used for cancer
do you know which cancer breast cancer
absolutely correct so it is used for
breast cancer and guess what we all have
to thank bioinformatics you know why
because bioinformatics actually changed
the way people are actually diagnosed
I'm in not the way people are diagnosed
but how they are actually a treatment
protocol and actually these problem
orphans actually
so what the stomach that are like 200
actually bioinformatics thanks to
biometrics this is one of the early on
contributions of course there are lots
of other contributions so tamoxifen is a
magic bullet that is given to people
diagnosed with breast cancer right
meaning that once they diagnosed with
breast cancer and if they are
early-stage breast cancer they go
through maybe radiation therapy they go
through chemotherapy and in fact even
later streets once they go through their
treatment protocol some of them if they
are pre menopausal which means they're
below 50 years of age or whatever they
are given this drug for five years and
this is supposed to prevent recurrence
of your cancer right it's amazing right
the drug has existed for 34 years it's
really working like magic of course you
know what some people it works some
people it does not work which we already
talked about but now there is a test to
see whether this is going to work or not
and all of those things but and but they
have come up with a panel of 200 genes
and this is all came from informatics
bioinformatics now they have come up
with a 22 panel gene which is called
encore typing so every patient is
actually this testing uncle typing they
look at what are the genes that are
expressed in their cancer and they give
a score between 1 to 30 and if the score
is like less than 7 then you don't have
to keep monitoring them every six months
with a mammogram with an ultrasound and
all of those things right that saves
them from radiation that saves money as
well so now if you have a score of say
27 28 then these patients are monitored
very closely because the recurrence of
this cancer is really high and so then
they are monitored so you know what so
informatics has played a significant
role in all of these things and the
other example is lymphomas like
leukemias lymphomas the classifications
of lymphomas came from bioinformatics
again from you know expression
microarray expression data analysis
right so there are lots of different
things that all of these omics have
actually contributed to
so this is pretty much where you know
all the contributions are now of course
it looks like I do have enough time for
questions and answers and discussions
now I would say this is not the end it
is not even the beginning of the end but
it is perhaps the end of the beginning
so if you keep reading it your head is
going to roll because you don't know if
I am saying it is actually the beginning
or I'm actually I'm saying it's an end
but I think it's a beginning of you know
it's actually the beginning of something
again so because we have actually
transformed all of this that analysis
and all of those things right so now if
of course you know I'm going to you know
if you have computers I don't know if
you all actually have a computer then
you actually can I'm actually going to
we just can actually I just want to show
you this I'm just gonna place this into
your chat box so I really like this and
I think this is something that you can
actually look at and you actually just
can actually take a walk right so this
is actually something that I teach my
when I teach high school students and
everyone who is really new I think this
is actually very very exciting right so
you can actually this tells you for each
chromosome it tells you you know you can
actually look at for each chromosome you
can actually look at what are the
polymorphisms that actually have been
identified this is actually probably not
updated fully but then at least you know
it this is actually a good start to
understand the chromosomes and what are
the polymorphisms and it actually tells
you what diseases are actually caused
for for example this particular position
it's this is particularly een and it
actually tells you what all of these
different things are and so you can
actually this it tells you that
this gene is actually involved in making
this firm and all of those things and
then it can actually tell you that this
gene is actually one that induces tissue
repair and so you know there are lots of
so you can actually I really like this
because you can just play around with
you know all of these different things
and you know learn about what are the
different chromosomes that are actually
really really important in you know
different aspects of different things
right so right now what I will do is I
will wait before if I were if you know I
can add on more things to what I said
but let me first answer all of your
questions because we just have ten more
minutes I just want to answer your
questions so that I'm not talking into
the last very minute so I would really
encourage any discussion points you have
and we can actually talk I know there
were some questions that I did not
answer along the way so I am ready for
your let's have a discussion if I earn
of course I have some questions for you
as well so that can actually you know so
did did I miss any questions picture if
you can actually tell me the questions
that I missed and I can we can actually
discuss I I see everything is covered
right now okay so okay so are there any
any more questions okay are there any
open sources to study omics okay well
there are which is you know you're going
to learn a lot of omics resources that
we are going to cover as I told I told
you early on and there is another
website called the omics world and that
is actually going to give you
practically thousands of thousands of
tools and resources that you can each
you can do for each type of omics right
I can actually show you that at the very
end when we actually summarize all of
our you know data for this week but
there are lots and lots of different
topics and I would recommend all of you
to read the database article that I
actually sent that
actually gives you the list of
recommended resources for each of the
different things because those are
actually someone has actually physically
gone there and actually looked at each
of the resource to make sure that the
data there is actually reliable because
you know what we can spend a lot of time
doing experimentation on something that
actually may not even be reliable right
you can spend the whole so I would
recommend you go and look at that
article that and follow all the list of
resources that's there in that article I
would highly recommend that and rather
than being a part of any organizational
universe like I am not a straight up now
how do I do it privately you mean you
want to privately in terms of learning
the resources Parimala is that your
question
basic information session so let me see
how do okay yeah so you can actually I
think you can now register to Pine
biotech without any you don't have to be
afflicted to any university or
institution I don't know if that's what
you're asking
and how do snips and introns influence
drug effectiveness so that's actually a
very good question super now how does
snips and so so right now it is actually
a grey zone because as you know that it
is hard to figure out the effect of a
snip directly but what we are actually
doing is either implying mode right so
this snip is probably what we do is we
actually find the gene it's closest to
on either side upstream or downstream
genes or set of genes that this actually
this snip is actually very very close to
and then we figure out whether there is
any regulatory mechanisms from these
genes that is very close to this
particular snip and also the other way
that I personally use in my research is
I look at micro rna's as well and so
those are the different aspects that we
actually look at to figure out how do we
actually look at the effect of snips
yeah please actually you know put your
questions to everyone maybe okay so is
there any other questions that I missed
learning exploring and learning yeah so
I think there are lots of different
resources for learning I think I would
start with that paper and go through
resources but I would actually talk I
would actually start with all the
courses offered in fine biotech because
this those courses are phenomenal
in fact it's ridicu bioinformatics and
everything are phenomenal because you
can take it at your own pace and learn
all the tools and I think what I like
about it is actually every tool I also
explains why are using the tool where
it's coming from so if you're doing
self-study I would actually start with a
reliable resource and I think I've
tested and IV is fine by that guide
that's what my students use as well so I
would actually just start there
and if you want to do advanced things
that if there is something that's not
there then of course you can email
either Illya or myself friend maybe we
can direct you to some things I'll just
I can show you after you're done yeah
okay so um okay there are other messages
okay exploring okay for the band friend
to do they usually use non-coding
service to analyze data
so when you say non-coding service
Geoffrey I'm not sure what you mean by
non-coding servers but if you're talking
about cloud space and if that is
something is that what you're asking for
data analysis so a touchdown we do have
you know we have data space in the cloud
and for me I have my own server and so
and then our university information
systems here a judgment has many servers
that we actually can use I don't
that is actually that is actually a
question I think referring to the
comment that I made about the tea buying
for server because you young students
they don't need to learn coding to use
it we upload on the cloud and we focus
more on analysis I think Elia is going
to give us like a walkthrough so that
it's easier for everyone to understand
how it works and it can definitely be
used for research because researchers
are using it all the time because what
you are actually doing at the end of the
day is analysis which is more important
so I think helium can cover that up yes
so um so I think there's a question
about a book on Pharma to a
pharmacogenetic in pharmacogenomics I
actually have an outstanding book that I
actually use for my teaching purposes of
pharmacogenomics and I don't have it
with me at this moment in time it's in
my shelf in the other room but I will be
sure to pass that on to you tomorrow
please ask if you're there tomorrow I'm
not sure if you're coming tomorrow but
if you are please ask me that question
again and I will make sure that I get
the book that I use personally use for
that books okay Elia you wanted a few
minutes to show something I guess maybe
you can okay
great thank you very much this was a
very insightful presentation can I
assume ice cream marriages yes okay so I
even shared with you guys so those of
you coming tomorrow I will definitely
into the words
so I wanted to make sure that everyone
also understands where to find some of
these resources that we have been
mentioning as I mentioned in the very
beginning of the session after you
register and complete your registration
you become a part of this program and
you have a dedicated page here where you
will have access
to a forum which is private to the
participants of this program we will
post here the recordings of these
sessions answer any technical problems
that you face doing the assignments or
downloading things and things like that
will pose your practice datasets that we
will use in the sessions any questions
that we don't have time to cover in the
online session like today you can
continue putting them right here
highlight top performers so people that
are very active and do a lot of you know
projects and work on the coursework we
will post them here and any other topics
that you will find here so we will just
continuously expand this there is a post
if you look in chat we just have a blog
post about how to set up the how to set
up I'm oh so beep so if you could put
that there as well and that will give
you an example of okay there we go
so that that's an example of how you can
find for example you know a short
tutorial and follow it after the session
so in this first week especially we will
rely on mo and here you will see I see
in 3d and mo just instructions on how to
register and download and you'll see
some of the useful links here as well
about mo if you're just getting started
and then I see in 3d so Mohit Mazumdar
who also has a PhD in computational
biology put together this short tutorial
and as we go through some of these other
tools you'll see a lot more reference
material here as well also as you saw
Sona
Vasudha mentioned a number of different
resources that you can look into NCBI
you know and all these different
repositories where you have their data
or you have some tools to explore that
data so if we focus on a specific
section like that we'll all
so post a little tutorial here that you
can follow to navigate and explore
what's in there
so the other resource that we keep
mentioning is this platform so I just
briefly wanted to show you what we are
talking about so that you understand the
level of complexity that you should be
relating for it is a tool used by
researchers and we offer it as a
research solution however we use it a
lot for education even starting at the
high school level and I'll give you an
example
so you mentioned all transcriptomics as
one of the type of onic data and to
process transcriptomic data from
next-generation sequencing it requires a
number of different steps to really put
together a table of gene expression so
just as an example you can see here a
pipeline builder this is using a demo
data set but the explanation of how to
build this pipeline is very simple for
you to follow us you don't need any
coding you don't need to setup any
resources on your own computer it's a
cloud cloud-based system once you start
you will be guided and so you will have
only a limited number of selection where
you can select for example to do
pre-processing if you do pre-processing
then you will see that your next
selection is changing based on the
previous selection that you did and
building a pipeline is very simple of
course it is you know more in-depth
explanations are given inside and we
even have courses specifically
explaining each one of these steps why
do you do it and what type of data do
you need to do it and what will be the
outcome so the outcomes are going to be
using some example data sets that you
can actually download and check some of
these methods especially the ones
designed around specific types of
downstream analysis steps will provide
you with an R script that you can
download so a lot of times for example
here you can see a did principal
component now
and I can download an our script we have
an additional playground for coding for
those of you that are interested in
coding and this is also something that
you won't get access to if you are
participating in this program so some of
these methods this is more a little bit
for the second part of the program where
you'll see that the exact same method
that is described there will provide you
with a tutorial where you can learn the
code and after you're learning the code
you can try that code modifying it to
see how it works so just an explanation
that this resource sorry this
centralized resource will show you how
you can attend the sessions so we will
be emailing the Xoom links but you can
see all of the sessions and the upcoming
session will be highlighted here you
will get additional resources and all of
your questions answered on forum here
you will find the coursework that is
associated with this program
specifically and in the coursework again
for completing each one of these courses
you get a separate certificate that is
besides the program certificate this is
just for completing the independent work
that you do in these courses a lot of
the coursework utilizes some element
like the platform that I just showed you
over here and as you can see the
platform covers a number of these
different types of omics data so we'll
talk about some of these types of data
including finding those snips and
analyzing gene expression and also
looking at microbiome data that we can
analyze for diversity of different
microbes so again if you are already a
member then you can start navigating
some of these resources if you're not a
member yet you can still complete your
registration today and you will be able
to access a lot of these materials as
soon as you complete your registration
okay are there any questions about and
I may add something yeah yeah so there
is a question that I got from one email
and I think it might be a question for
everybody is which is the log in 2d bio
info so you have two separate accounts
one is the science coach website where
you have already registered and the
other is City bio info I have emailed
everybody except for say Amy so you all
should have that it says right now
please use that email and username and
password to log into G bio info and this
is separate but in your activity you
will be able to keep track of you could
show like how the activities tracked but
they can see or I mean the pipeline's we
are running yeah so typically as you can
see you will see your account right here
and under your profile you will see all
of the activity that is related to
whatever course or pipeline that you are
running and so here you can see my
activity you can see that I finish a
pipeline and or that I start a pipeline
and for others you will see that you can
complete a specific activity in coding
or you can also see an activity related
to coursework that you complete so
you'll see the stream and then also your
points will accumulate right here so if
you look at your overall point progress
this is a metric that we use to make
sure that we understand your activity
understand the number of courses that
you are completing or the pipeline's
that you are running and and can address
specific types of questions that you
might have to do any type of a pipeline
because if you run in a pipeline and
something doesn't work we can directly
go into that pipeline see your uploaded
data see the settings that you've done
and if there's some mistake we can
either correct it or inform you about
how to correct it on
all right well I don't see any more
questions and we're already running a
little bit over time so I think we had a
great presentation today from dr. so
another suitable thank you very much for
those of you coming tomorrow we will
meet at the same time you will receive
an email with your zoom link to access
tomorrow's session and again thank you
for joining today we're looking forward
to continuing this program with all of
you thank you all it was an amazing
batch for me I love interaction and you
guys were very interactive and I just
love that and let's keep it going
hopefully you learned something today
and you know if there are any more
questions that you can think of you know
please bring it tomorrow to class and we
can actually discuss anything you may
have the goal is for example that you
need to you know get something out so
we're all here to help have a great day
everyone I know some of you it's a it's
nighttime and some of you you know all
those time zones thank you for making
the time and Thank You Leah and Thank
You beep Cheyenne Mohit okay thank you
thank you so much